of no importance and
yet they knew about this for me
there is no return
hold on somebody forced you not just me
my brother too they drugged us
desecrated my body
and all the while they mocked me
how can you do this to a fellow human
being and still
mock them
how about you brother he's still with
him yes
i was first then they were trying to
decide
how how to modify him
you look like someone who can reason
with these people
i beg you please help my brother
i only hope it is not too late i do not
wish for him to end up like
like i have
fine i'll help but just so you know
things might get ugly
maelstrom doesn't mess around there must
be some other way
help us please but without any bloodshed
i beg you i'll see what i can do
either way your brother's getting out i
do not know how to thank you
they're keeping him in a shop just north
over here
you shall find it next to the road along
the docks
how poetic a monk in distress
they should include this in your epic
what are you gonna do cross your legs
and meditate till they drop dead
i wish you dropped dead
so
why the [ __ ] do i always gotta be the
lookout
listen what if instead of an arm we
shipped to take a piss take a mic
to the loser
[Music]
stick
[Music]
us do not do this
invitations against my police please i
do not want them
calm down it's over now i'm not with
them
so what are you doing here
what happened he's walking by
caught some lame jokes about metal monks
think about maelstrom
they're never just joking nah
the truth your brother sent me he didn't
want the same thing to happen to you
you thank you for coming to my rescue
but my life is not worth the death of
others one good deed does not justify
the suffering you have saw
you have committed evil in its purest
form
i liked your brother more
your brother's waiting for you not far
from here
first i must catch my breath and then i
shall go
it is him who shall need saving now who
knew
monks were ungrateful little brats maybe
you should apologize for saving this
organic ass too
tired of [ __ ] saying there are good
and bad people in this world
there are only good choices and shitty
ones
must have made a good one cause why else
would karma leave all this sweet gear
just
ripe for the picking i like where you're
going with this